Piper was the name of the short film
that played before finding dory it was
fantastic ok so I just watched finding
dory this film is yeah it's pretty
fantastic it hits all the right notes it
has a ton of humor a ton of imagination
and most importantly it maintains a huge
heart basic plot of the film as it takes
place approximately one year after the
events of Finding Nemo Dory now lives
with marin an emo and something starts
to happen where dory you know a fish
with short-term memory loss begins to
remember who her family actually is like
her her biological parents should you
said that first son making it confusing
then with the help of nemo and marin
Dory sets up an epic adventure to track
down and reunite with her parents now
like a lot of films there's pros and
cons with this movie for me there's not
like super heavy cons really first like
to touch on the pros this film
obliterated what I was super worried
about to begin with when I heard the
plot of the movie and then I saw the
first trailer I honestly thought this
was gonna be a movie made solely for
marketing purposes I thought that maybe
Disney your pics are was thinking Ellen
DeGeneres's hot [ __ ] right now so we
should capitalize off her stardom and
turn her supporting comedic character
into the lead of the sequel I was
worried he's gonna be a sword with too
many cheap gags and lazy comedic
dialogue and I thought they were gonna
beat the joke of dory forgetting to
death however I was thoroughly impressed
with this movie the story that they have
of Dora is really a rewarding experience
but it does well up front as it shows a
story at a very young age all the way up
until they like the moments right before
she meets Marin as we saw on fighting
email could have said that smoother to
Pixar has this amazing job at creating
very touching and heartbreaking opening
sequences this review is meant to get
you to go watch the movie because I want
you to watch it it's not a spoiler
review so I'm not going to go into too
many details about the opening does look
at the heart tickles really well now you
see the primary setting in this movie is
at a marine life Institute it's like a
sea world type of plates now they had a
lot to explore in terms of like the the
fish creatures the fish creatures and at
the aquarium there are a lot of cool
animals to cut away to as well see now
my prom with this
is also the same reason why I respect it
let's see if this makes sense because of
where the adventure primarily takes
place the Avenger is for the most part
much smaller because you see like
finding Nemo is like a beautiful oceanic
exploration so because of the fact that
the first movie was already this grand
adventure through out the ocean it makes
sense that to go in another direction
they would make it more contained
however the end of the day it does leave
me as a viewer who loves the original to
go oh that's definitely a smaller
adventure though however in the
Institute there's an octopus named Hank
and he's played by Ed O'Neill who played
al bundy I'm married with children one
of the best shows of all time he's a
great character in some ways he doesn't
remind me about Bundy the guy seems like
he might have had like a glory day past
but now he just refuses to be in touch
with society or maybe I'm reading too
deep into it he's an important character
to this journey has a wonderful effect
on Dori and they honestly do a lot of
amazing character movement and animation
with his character like the way they
mess with his camouflage there's some
pretty cool stuff in there but then
there's that even some of the movement
with Hank kind of bothered me I know
this is an animated film about fish you
know of course there's going to be
ridiculous plot points however I can't
really find the words for it other than
I had to suspend my disbelief a little
bit no it's not to say that finding nemo
didn't have its moments where you're
like yeah a fish could you that out of
water i felt this movie had a few too
many of those moments I know look I'm
not reviewing fighting email right now
and we're doing finding Dory but hey i'm
gonna compare it sorry well finding nemo
did for me was it felt like it took me
into the world of the sea creatures you
know like it made me go kind of like
what toy story did with do my toys
really move around and talk when I'm not
around and kind of made me go maybe
that's what the life of you know Fisher
like I had all the technicalities down
from a great script a great direction to
great animation and great voiceover work
however the finding Dory world is a much
more heightened cartoony world
especially when it comes to the
characters of Marin and nima there's too
many times I was like there's no way a
fish can do or survive that I mean call
it nitpicky but I just felt like he kind
of told me out of the film for some
reason and a lot of very convenient
things consistently happen for these
characters like anytime a situation
seems bad
it's like no what no just look to your
left it's gonna be okay whereas I felt
like the situation's of Finding Nemo as
the journey progressed the situation's
just kept getting worse and worse as
opposed to here where I felt like a lot
of things sort of just fallen for their
lap when they need them going back to
marin an email i really didn't care for
them in this movie their story was
separate they're the ones who are
actually finding doors they serve a
purpose like in the beginning of dories
adventure like like very very beginning
of the Avenger but after that they kind
of don't serve a point at all and if
anything they kind of make things worse
however I want to make it clear right
here right now this film is still
wonderful can't help but give my
comparisons this is a review so will
share my criticisms but despite my
criticisms like I said earlier the pros
of this film greatly outweigh the cons
because in the end you see finding Dory
it's a different film it's been so many
years since finding nemo that it's safe
to say this is more than finding nemo
part to finding Dory is its own separate
movie so it doesn't need to try to be
finding him for what finding Dory is
it's an absolute delight it's just not
better than finding email oh yeah that's
my review of the film I don't believe in
rating systems but i'll give you a
consensus finding Dory is filled with
wonderful animation brilliant voiceover
work some hilarious moments its overall
just a great family film John Humphrey
listen guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe today and become a
reject and might be worth everyone's
time who knows let's jump in this
journey together you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and I guess
you can find us on vine we don't really
do finds that much anymore i have a
periscope account never use it even have
a you now account made like 40 bucks off
of there but you can't actually collect
your money until you make a hundred and
I had that was like close to a year ago
when I last to use it I really could be
more productive in the social media
world would expand my youtube career by
far I can become an internet sensation
but I'm kind of lazy